what up I'm black vets on Instagram at
black vets and I'm a vapor got first
smoke the vamp about three years ago oh
yeah what's up like babes here chosen
able to blow dumbass clouds with that
and when Instagram came out and your boy
got an account people realize like oh
[ __ ] this guy's trip kills the game and
that's that's where I'm at now did
pretty much my page started to grow
after some big pages started sharing my
content and here we are dead 91k vanalai
for black vibes
pretty much I wake up you know I have a
waking bed I'll just start vaping right
out of bed did and then from there I'll
go to my living room chilling that for a
while think of some dope-ass ideas I
could do to film for my Instagram then I
get outside go to the gym a little bit
workout you know straight up get you
know you can't just you can't be out
there looking like [ __ ] dude so that's
why your boy Blaine face does that then
after that dude dinnertime
your boy crushes it on something high in
protein obviously and then at night time
you know if more videos come to me I'll
film them if not then I'll just tell
them that I type in all caps to let
people know that everything that I do is
strapped urgent as [ __ ] and when it
comes to misspelling and screwin up
words and stuff I don't have time to
correct that [ __ ] dude you're black
virus is hella busy whenever I post a
meme I'm pretty much just trying to
relate to other people because everyone
pretty much has a face and they make
certain faces in certain situations and
so I like to relate to them by saying
this is the face that you would make in
this particular situation so one time I
was typing in front of a big eyes here
and straight-up realized like oh [ __ ]
this is the face that you would make if
you were vaping in front of a big guys
here dude and it was
my headers' hi Hatters hi camera - hi
Hatter's camera one hi Hitler's buzz
feed everyone in BuzzFeed hi haters
pretty much I have headers because it's
just people that are hella jealous of
your boy black vibes killing the game
and you know hey isn't anything more
than just confuse love it's people that
straight-up love you so much barso hella
jealous that they can't get on your
level that they stirred up have to spew
some kind of emotion towards you and it
usually is hate in the form of comments
that are that are not chill dude since I
started generating so much hate on my
Instagram my goal has changed from being
just top of the Vette game to now
putting out a message of goodness and
anti hate so my ultimate goal in three
years is to have a TED talk so if Ted if
you're listening out there dude I'm
trying to have a talk I can pretty much
film a video anywhere at any time you do
one right now I could do one right now
so I got to make sure that everything
looks good what up lights hair chillin
vaping at BuzzFeed Studios right now as
they make a viral video and so from
there what I'll do is I'll go through
and I'll drop that [ __ ] in iMovie and
I'll edit it
I'll put on some [ __ ] dope ass
dubstep and drop that [ __ ] it'll get
like 4k likes what up like I chair
chillin vaping at BuzzFeed studios right
now as they make a viral video I
straight up make hella viral videos but
this is one about your blood like that
that I didn't make
that's what's up dude